life hacks 1:06 big swingin dicks that's
like the the interpreter wet so the
family guy producers did a press
conference and they had someone doing
the sign language mm-hmm
and and he noticed and he was he started
saying more and more silly stuff in fact
we could could we include the clip of
this here too that is everyone look at
the sign language interpreter right now
[ __ ] [ __ ]
nobody's bring up [ __ ] that go on
within a second
giant BP flippity-floppity saggy dog
hello buck why that code was weird being
away and one hour back yeah I didn't
like be so pleased to be parked man me
too
so fly facts 106 principles for a
productive and efficient life each
remain a trendy you only be the trendy
it was fine it's just like [ __ ] what
where's the top I'm Ryan Sunday do you
do you do do I ruin it or do I know you
were is it endearing magic - no it's and
then Chris tries to reel it back someone
watching me you watching me graph but
I'm the ghost in the system right during
a line in the ointment it's gone let's
go in the pot right the first time in
three episodes you have a list I've some
knives for this earlier it's not very
comprehensive do you want do you want
just baked up I go to quit one quick on
good job throw one thing away per day
mmm all right as in like one empty
pocket Christmas No yeah one possession
that's pretty mning that you purchase
possessions are quicker than one a day
notice eventually you will know it's not
you could have ended with otherwise the
whole point would be don't be ridiculous
think of the rate Yubikey laying things
out now right if you if you're waiting
how life how long don't have to continue
this fall so the idea is you know 100
things should know she live a particular
purpose in your life and a lot of people
have a lot of bloated stuff
there's an article of a guy that has 22
possessions and only they'll all be mint
oh yeah yeah it's like a really
expensive set of hard wearing boots mm a
MacBook Air
okay click mm-hmm like go give it to
charity show up or sell it
eBay whatever or eBay fair enough
I just think it leads to a more
streamlined existence you're minimalist
life space will be LLL beat idea monthly
clearer
really
most people feel like I'm gonna have a
big sack big sort our big tidy up my
bollocks just throw one thing away
better mm-hmm and then before you know
it six months later you're not batching
you know what else thanks they're very
effectively the way you're it's a habit
it's a process girl rather than an
outcome go okay you go even if it's a
good one by the muck also a fitness tip
best thing that you can do for your
upper body is get a pull-up bar in your
house the pull-up is like the squatter
of the upper body and if you just have
it in your house especially if you rent
somewhere and you're like I can't good
the walls of the dough cuz it'll be
annoying just get rid of the lever ones
that you just hook it on when you pull
on one side it's completely staples if
you have it come to levers and can come
to leave a cantilever cantilever counter
leave it a cantor leave a cantilever
force down is quite Levi out to you so
you get one of them every time you walk
past it do 5 pull-ups or like that's it
okay mindset what Mike said so yeah pick
the match number of reps you can do
divide it by two and do that many number
of reps so if you can do 10 pull-ups in
one set do five if you can only do three
do one pull-up if you can't do any
pull-ups join me but jump to the top let
yourself down as slow as you can all the
way Tom don't do any of this kind of
done like jump to the top make yourself
all the way down
that's all joining to do it across
VidCon yeah yeah well if you give me
pain to waste your time much what a fun
way seems like you could buy the VA
program that is a program that we have
which added and I'm people think I'm
lying about this it added 25 kilograms
to my bench press in eight weeks Johnny
saw it happen if I watched it to some
people that might not sound like a lot
when I'm making new games I see it went
from a hundred and fifteen two hundred
and forty but you'd already got close to
peak performance I was yeah
oh yeah that was after a lot of training
wasn't it it was that was after
seven years of training added an inch
inch and a half to my chest and back
think the difference in the photos
probably got slightly leaner if anything
so it's a hard program it is an art
program
procopius comm /search on the part of
the tape okay I'm going to optimus pro
previous icon for such product v-taper
and then credit card will make sure I'll
just create a fitness.com /v taper they
you know if I get time this is up and
less thing get it up right now so my one
um anchor USB hub believer and Cal Eva
without to you turkey breast so everyone
will know that almost everything in
their home of their bedroom especially
is charged by USB and I recently got a
lamp which is charged by us missin also
awesome toothbrushes my us got USB
lumpiness at all twice I think it plugs
into years but well the charging thing
so it's a battery powered rail of and
then the other end of that um so you've
got millions my doesn't even charge it
just needs to always be a menace
millions of dispersed products which
require a USB plug to fit in to get your
anchor make one I think the one I've got
is an eight stack so it's like a little
rectangle well that big maybe a few
inches by a few inches by USB stick and
it's got eight of them no surely this is
similar similar but not new it's not
that one is it and it's just gonna fix
all of your problems everything comes
out of one area you're never gonna lose
plugs again one thing is plugged in you
don't need a multi socket and it's just
fantastic it's been an absolute game
changer if you show any wall sockets
that have a USB slot no cuz I've got
this okay yeah I've got one I use it for
my lamp that needs to be permanently
plugged into a USB so you've bought a
lamp and then bought the stop you for
the lamp or will they couldn't or
coincidental yeah but like you can also
use it obviously for
that's like Phillips using its that by a
switch for your smart lamp very smart my
shout out to Michael kazoo from brute
strength for making me jealous of his
USB hub Wiles in Texas I got back in as
I need one of them it's fantastic years
well there's never enough USBs is that
there is now with this hug so what's
next
Jane um get a monthly massage mm-hmm
where from why do people go if they dug
to have someone good because finding a
massage therapist yeah I was gonna yeah
you say if you're in the Northeast for
for serious I I'm quite limited on
availability but weekends here's the
affiliates game there's only one I got
all over again so that city you have to
listen to normally a lecture small arms
three times speed I'll give you a
discount if I can listen to a lecture on
three time speed would you yeah I'll
give you five pounds off otherwise you
can listen to whatever of your choosing
for a 5% on so as you can see your own
music what about if it's silence is that
just the price the midpoint yeah 250 but
so it's what it's it puts you in a
volume of tissue work you would never
put yourself of yourself
it hurts so you would never do it
yourself and it just prevents things
from getting too out of hand and once a
month isn't so frequent that it's like
financially insane I mean once what this
look quite a bit but I think for return
with it less it's gone get a shoehorn ah
so I did analysis of this which is like
let's say you wear a lot of converse and
vans and the Kabul any few that's just a
little willing to try and get on Rose
brogues are yeah possibly if you or if
you get painful heels or blisters on
your heels you need to protect them
if you spend let's say you take your
shoes on and off average three four
times a day takes you 15 to 30 seconds
per shoe let's say 15 seconds that's 30
seconds per time multiply by 4 that's 2
minutes per day
multiply that by 365 or about seven
hundred and thirty minutes that's 12
hours of time Jesus that you putting
your shoes on who what you know yeah
that you putting your shoes on what can
you get that down to this year oh come
on I feel like my maths is wrong cuz I
doesn't seem that bad really
and also like not some few minutes it's
2 minutes a day though just 2 minutes
times 3 6 5 730 it's correct okay yeah
fine so you can get 100 of your life
what you're saving by using them so okay
so it's the last 12.1 hours let's say
you want hourly rate is 10 pounds an
hour
you're saving 121 pounds over a year of
human man-hours and why don't how much
profit potential you could generate but
you don't like your shoes on instantly
the shoe yeah I need to work out the
saving time so let's say you save five
seconds okay I think you probably cut it
down to a quarter yeah 25 he's not like
anything to get charmed in it get you
save your thumb skin is what everyone
wants a bit of nice thumb so it's close
kin bakery so eBay 70 P free postage no
Avant you don't want you or you could do
what these two did which was the most
beautiful gift I've ever received for my
birthday
they got me a proper weapon of a
shoehorn like why is it probably fifty
inches long and it's like cold rolled
steel or something it's lovely
we also got you some farm and you ate
him was it was Parma haha Mahone Haram
Haram and a green eggs and promise of
Tank Engine God yeah that leads quite
nicely into to that I want to do which
are more I guess friendship based or
conceptual based first one is tell your
friends that you miss them so this is
something that I read in the 6-minute
diary which you have heard me speak
about a lot and is potentially you're
not coming like back on this episode
where it says your friends will
appreciate you telling them to go
thinking of them and so many times
you'll think about someone that you care
about whether it be a friend or a family
member and you won't do anything about
it like that is the lowest hanging fruit
of a nice gesture
he's you send and receive sight messages
on a
hourly basis on your phone just when
that happens now whenever I get a pang
of thinking about someone I just tend to
tell them I try my best to go think
about you man hope you good or send a
message to my mom my dad or ask how the
dogs are like and it's just it's a nice
little rule of thumb the same way that
some people have got like trigger
numbers like wherever they see the
number 21 it reminds them to be mindful
or whatever it might be that's kind of
the same thing for me and on the side of
that is be the guy who organizes the for
the NGO who organizes stuff for your
friends so I've got a lot of mates who
complained that their friends never want
to do things like that they just toss
around they'll be always just go at the
pub or do whatever you know the powers
in your hands to do this and if you
continue like I need to get you two to
go Wyson yeah you are definitely that
person thin end of the wedge what Chris
did so me and Chris were wanted to go to
Iceland Chris tonight Chris and I I took
the I took the plunge I was like okay
it'll be a nice thing I got the gitis on
the way but Jonny was like oh no I
really can't afford to go to Iceland at
the moment it's gonna be nine and a half
thousand pounds for everything and so
Chris super thing bought him for
everything yeah
bought him the plane ticket to Iceland
and then you're you're the dick if you
don't go because that was someone's got
your penny sterling so that was a
service that was mine
but then thus the reason it's thin end
of the wedge is because that's really
just cranking the door open but the real
cost of Iceland is once you get there
and you buy a ready meal from a
supermarket and it's nine point five
thousand you can sense the Kristin are
just lives off Domino's the whole time
there was not a half thousand pounds per
pizza it was cheaper Domino's was like
standard price was no one else's it was
this domino game franchise the most
affordable thing like you'd be better
off just having Domino's for every was a
man who built this house out of them
it's cheaper than brick yeah fine
well it would be that's the thing that
well that's another life hack like
you're an idiot if you pay full price
for Domino's because they've constantly
got discount super cheese I think so
expressly we always respect models now
we ordered the proto half a grand of
Domino's to a staff induction in couple
weeks yes that's a lot of Domino's with
vouchers as well two for Tuesday's good
god that would look like busts a shop we
had to do that we had to ring them in
their pants mmm
well the day before one go just to let
you spread of FYI you're right I have
the mother lode send you would shove
this like right in your dog but book
fried up as a holiday cuz tomorrow
I'm hey uniquely revenue target I'm
right at Johnny already catch me off
guard every time another ready for the
next time quickfire life hack CIA this
is a biggie is self monetize
okay so I hit an example of a guy who
okay so step back if we assume that AI
machine learning etc is slowly taking
over a lot of jobs so let's say but in
20 years time a good chunk of jobs that
are have a fairly manual component to
them will be largely automated so you
need to not wait until that's happening
to go oh [ __ ]
I'm unemployed I need to find something
else to do there's an example of a guy
who are herding a podcast recently you
used to work in the same area I used to
work in so used to it for a big for
accountancy firm
so it's happening he was like literally
they are hiring less people per year
because of all this automation left and
started selling a product online using
online marketing etc of just how to get
a job at one of these firms and there's
more per year than when he was working
there which is a bit mad so ironically I
like he just at the point the point
birth mother self monetize is like
everyone has a something that they could
just coach or offer just start doing it
as a side hobby this is the guy from
clickfunnels right but not him no but he
does that's one of the things that he
says everyone's an expert in so so if
you want to get expert secrets let us
know send you a link speak to the guys
that's a really good point I felt like I
saw some guy that site following on
Twitter the other day came up with an
unbelievable side business that everyone
could do search local businesses on
Google or Facebook when you view the
page look for the ones that say is this
your business claim it then call that
business and say you're not doing online
marketing your competitors taking your
money away from you very easily learn
online marketing and do the marketing
for them yeah they go there's probably a
20 grand of your business visit in your
back pocket there are so many things
that like so if you are a
twenty-something Europe like or theity
something whatever like you're fairly
familiar with Facebook social media etc
there are so many business owners who
are 50 something who have no interest in
learning weren't raised with that level
of technology and you can just provide a
service online any pajamas but then look
I'll teach you how to tweet face and
tweet faces to it yourself new book the
whole thing you but and it's a that is a
side income that in some cases can
eclipse weaker in the year it's a good
point it's like you probably have an
expertise in at least two or three
things that you maybe not even
considered you wouldn't even consider to
be an expertise in like the guy on how
to get a job at the company that he
works at that's not something that
immediately comes to mind it's like I've
got a job here so therefore I know how
to get the job
exhausting something we say when we're
teaching pts how to move online is just
staying one chapter ahead of the people
you help him says in the film couch
couch me if he can't he pretends to
teach your clutter he teaches a class by
just reading one chapter ahead of where
the class actually is for a whole Tim
they're like if you're if you know a
little bit about something more than
someone else you can help essentially an
expert where you're you up exactly and
actually that person probably doesn't
want someone who's ten steps or 20 steps
ahead because you've lost touch it's
unrelated well yeah no that's good don't
wait until hey I takes a job to get
another room did you see I did a tweet
today I think one of you guys replied to
it about self-driving cars yeah there we
go
oh yeah so there was this this statistic
that was listening to about self-driving
cars will save 1 million road deaths per
year and people are still arguing over
which group of pedestrians it would hit
if it was presented with this
existential as though humans make the
optimal decision that's the
ridiculousness
so yes it's like and this is what I said
the perfect thing that said on the
message that week was we would sooner
die of our own volition hmm then live at
the behest of a computer hmm well so the
via the response was some people after
September the 11th many people decided
to drive interstate because they were
afraid of September the 11th happening
again which ironically is so unlikely
that the same terrorist event is going
to happen again because why do you think
the most security is going to be
immediately after an airplane incident
exactly and terrorists don't like the
night rise let's double down on the
motorways I'm just convinced that the
motorways of bloody where is a look John
John Carr for security yeah exactly so
my life Park on the note of you saying
having a trigger number
yep that reminds you to do something is
so you can do digital or analog the
digital version has an app on iPhone
called alarmed
so alarm D that just allows you to set
and the the image is actually like a
little bit of string around someone's
finger that's what people used to do so
you can wear a ring or you can wear a
bracelet or something that also reminds
you of that and every time you become
aware of it what you notice it on your
body and it all you set alarm to go off
at certain intervals throughout the day
you can do the the habit that you're
looking to instill for me it's deeper
breathing so I've got the demon
breathing on us now and it makes a
really unintuitive like it's quite
enough sorry what does it do it's nice
lovely and so it doesn't vibrate or
anything it's just enough to for you to
notice it other people won't even
register and not the logical thoughts on
breath yeah that's a really nice way to
do it I might do that for making sure
that my posture and Col don't exactly
yeah alarmed very nice indeed
I'm gonna do okay so video Gardein will
love the fact that he's got some partner
footage for this but I recently decided
to purchase a pregnancy colour so glad
congratulations yeah as you will see
here let me show you boys smells dogs
all right there's a toss another life
hack for next time the smell of his room
in horror happens Charlie
Chris that is not what I expected like
it's a little man yeah there we go
they look like legs Jennifer go ego in
the middle oh well then you're gonna be
on top Oh Jeremy
this unit is sleeping in Armenia chris
is fantastic being slowly eaten by this
mattress is di lovely so I can't
describe just it feels like your body
just goes silent oh my back oh yeah
awful when we go away yeah how long have
we been gone for that's the thing I
don't know we'll never someone may have
tampered with it yeah it's gone Rafael
we was gone it was pregnancy pillow it's
essentially a huge you as you've just
seen in the footage it's a big u-shaped
bastard that lives in me bed and as
opposed to having a normal pillow and
not not being able to support yourself
when you roll over if you're a slightly
heavier guy like we may be it means I
don't like I like sleeping on my side
but I don't like folding over without
support underneath and I never really
knew what I was missing until I had a
pregnancy pillow so being able to put
something that's both between your legs
and that your top arm can rest on takes
so much of the pressure off the like
chest already sat over a computer all
day opening up your scapula opening up
your back into closing off on your chest
and then you go to bed and mimic the
same position the idea as well but that
by having your legs slightly apart if
you didn't have that your spine sags
because you've got your head elevated
and then the rest of your body is down
like that and then your legs together so
your spine is laterally sagging down
whereas if you have your legs slightly
apart just straightens things up a bit
and then if you do Johnny's tip from
lifehacks 104 I think one of does it 105
where you have in that position and you
have the pillow
don't I get to don't forget the towel or
a towel or towel roll inside wedged
gotta mean the gap here much in my hands
a towel roll much my husband behind to
tower over this hands my hand isn't that
much easier it's it I'm certain what's
this that's my hand this is a tall okay
and then if you can't if you down the
pregnancy pillow
just like when you're the I have a three
pillow set up unfortunately would you
not consider pregnancy pillow I've been
worried about the heat I'm well up for a
pregnancy pillow but it contravenes my
estrogen experiment at the moment
because it's made of polyurethane and so
can we
polyethylene one of them it's the it's
the complexity of that sentence like I
know obviously I know exactly what you
mean but I know it's true actually that
sentence it contravenes my exclusion
experiment because yeah like Walter
there's another what's the reach of an
experiment what happened probably
finished calm /ii sturgeon how do you
spell is treating with an E
no no what happened when I lit some
candles when we all came round to my
house I'm a dope certain you go upset
because it was gonna ruin your
experiment to try and improve your free
testosterone isn't the free is it not
the net for me it's my free all that is
the net isn't it total and free my
Turtles normal my free is subnormal so
prepping for socialiste review an
undefeated I'm just normal gonna make
those two links before this goes the
tots are on my tots are through the roof
so who just did what you did
so it's all it's really nice you can get
one on Amazon the link will be in the
show notes below and it's like 20 point
for like a like a smaller one I'm gonna
upgrade to the one that you sent me
that's nice fifty quid but yeah it looks
worth it yeah it's the problem with my
one is I have a pregnancy pillow and
then I need to put another one on top
because it is thin on the ground isn't
it soon
so my teen pregnancy pillows how would
you who's the guy who's the guy that did
the top deal who's like who's the guy
that did the sleep thank you Sarah Kelly
Starrett was the one actually that was
linked in life Fox 105 check that out
and he did the sleep posture thing right
how would you utilize a pregnancy pillow
with that would you just go one I'm
under one on over yeah he talks about to
either be lying any back pillow at the
hamstrings if you're lying so I fill up
between your legs
yeah and then he has the so that display
which is kind of a pregnant spell that's
already doing as long as you are not
doing so that I think what he's trying
to get away from it people go like this
mmm
and then that you know that you're like
sap on your show lying on your show or
like the superhuman yes I mean even if
you don't have a pregnancy pillow you're
not prepared to make the move your
partner's going to say that what the
[ __ ] if you made this barrier between us
in the bed fall you know regular do you
travel a lot yeah whatever and how do
you know you're not women even if you're
not prepared to do that you can quite
easily like just getting used to
slotting that bottom arm underneath a
pillow and pushing the pillow in between
yourself and your shoulder even just
when you taught me that I was like why
do I not be that's what I do currently
because my pillow doesn't compress very
much yeah but I'm gonna go for the next
stage into the world of tal I think cuz
I need to sleep on the floor though I do
sleep on the floor so I think that
sounds like I'm just I know that what
you wanted me to mention that to the
listeners a harmony it'll be a joke that
Youssef sleeps on the floor
Joanie and Chris made a funny
exaggeration because he's an Arab
actually that you actually do I do and
I'm considering getting some wooden
pallets just how long did we fight with
you to try and get you to get better
weeks and you could have had 90 days
times 3 when you bought your house to to
when you moved in mm-hmm so I've done
four months now
of sleeping on the floor good on a
mattress topper on a mattress topper
just to stop the joints from yeah so I
did it as a journalistic piece and I'm
writing an article video about it it's
coming out soon on prepping for home
forced are sleeping on the floor I'm
sure to call it full / floor floor
fine enough making these links on the
fly but it just means creating will work
for us out yeah
oh good so then the links that you say
don't exist no yes but they will yes so
they do they do exist now okay so net
overall are you gonna have to sleep on
the floor forever no there have been
some benefits some downsides but you'll
have to see the article and the video to
find out right nice man you weren't
ready said you get sucked in the
direction now we're gonna be talking
about sleep in Johnny just got
completely sucked off off
did I accessory it off in a direction
which I reckon so you know actually I'm
going to do give a coffee give a
caffeine you're gonna give that coffee
are you gonna do giving up coffee
so I've already given a coffee than a
month not anymore yeah
and you haven't even had you fit a
really recipes you nothing would ever
[ __ ] that for some reason they call it
fit II how much coffee were you having
resolved how much on average five cups a
day the flat teaspoons big heap teaspoon
so I have an espresso machine
the little capsules yeah but like so I
have like two at home morning and then
sometimes like go out maybe have two in
a coffee shop lunchtime yeah and the
trouble is reckless
yeah well that looking about my looking
back now it is reckless what was any
like it resets not only a sensitivity to
caffeine but also yeah so I was on
holiday with my girlfriend ordered my
second sore at breakfast I ordered my
second coffee air at breakfast because
I'm like I used to have this I may have
even said on this podcast you service
are cheap like anyone who gives her
coffee is just [ __ ] got nothing to do
like go find me someone who drinks a lot
coffee I'll show you someone who gets a
lot done they've got a big to-do list
like they're probably quite an ambitious
las niñas
big penis massive deadlift all those
things and a nice bench press
and so I just almost almost wore it as a
badge of honor that a driver lobby and
if this is about is it the culture
around that certainly in the fitness
industry of like you know how I feel on
a mundo got coffee etc etc so she said I
bet you can go without coffee for 30
days and my median like [ __ ] you yes I
can
kicked in and before I knew it I'd
committed to it so the first thing I
really like my eighty this thing I did
was a Amazon bought a I was like running
it really into teeth that Tizen mint so
I ordered like a year of amate puer tea
Sencha green tea and I was making these
concoctions and like this is taste awful
trying to convince myself at ease that
it was fine remembering that we're all
starting at what's up chat listening
witnessing the Jordanaires
discuss the finer points of how to get
off being so the the weirdest thing
about it was I think because I had I was
sobbing some tea so I was allowed any
tea I wanted just no coffee second of
decaf so I was trying to get myself away
from seeing coffee as less minding my
tea volumes and everything yeah
because Dean has more caffeine than
coffee apparently but it's just it's
just that it doesn't can't diffuse yeah
so I think I probably my caffeine intake
went down from properly 600 milligrams a
day to less and a hundred milligrams a
day and some days nothing at all for
someone that doesn't know what 600
milligrams is likes not very much a shot
of espresso is roughly sixty to eighty
usually sixty so otherwise known as
pointless and not know and not go with
140 yeah so that that's like a that's a
decent like a nice start at dose okay
sorry I'm like what were the effects
that 30 days of no caffeine elicited
sleep so I was expecting some sleep
benefits few headaches like but feeling
a bit frustrated and generally
underwhelmed and under well under well
where the under I cannot find it
sylia was improved an unbelievable
amount so like I think we were recording
a podcast one evening after I'd be
dating for our week and I was like I
can't keep my eyes up and he was like
half night falling asleep so how does it
take until you you start you sort of
steep improvements I was almost almost
instant he said it was a weekend that
you then we were doing a podcast but
just generally like 9:30 just oh I see
Stephen is a steep improvements you mean
you're tired up in the night I'm tired
tired any evening without you having to
like try and wind down I think he helps
out alone I was going back onto coffee
news I had another like a two or three
day so I've been off coffee for a few
years not like cold turkey two or three
days of like I'm gonna you know ease
myself back into coffee and just having
one in the mornings I never used to fall
asleep during the day and once I started
doing that I noticed though in the
afternoon I was falling asleep a slump
and I think it's because there's a
carryover effect reducing my sleep
quality in the night time zone to that
and then you're more tired during the
day and then you're having to just
stumble your way into like having more
coffees to keep yourself propped up and
then there was a time when you had a
slightly too heaped teaspoon of coffee
hot ranged 100 the whole day I bet
that's my message
me and Johnny just saying guys had a
heaped teaspoon of toffee this morning
cuz I'll have been like still weighing
niranda milligrams of caffeine probably
they've gone from like 65 to 80 or
something like that ruined me that's
right I've got the data to show for it I
can include nothing find the screenshot
so - I've been back on coffee for two
weeks and I went so the morning the
morning of me having my first coffee the
day before I realized that someone hit
still in my data online
I started getting letters and I was like
for [ __ ] sake okay so go deal with this
but I was like no bollocks I'm going to
the coffee shop so I like delayed
dealing with it went to who's been
coffee if anyone's been there in
subtle lovely ordered an Aeropress
coffee so this this used to be like
bread and butter familiar this used to
be just like whereas this was like the
thing and the so extremely productive
morning I almost painfully productive
morning the next day had one as I write
want more of that I had a second one
massive mistake
Mac said mistake so we you know I wrote
a coaching call at a time and I remember
sitting there thinking like I've
literally overdone it here
you can't go back there's nothing you
can do undo button with copy or yes and
you feel it take you away and you're
like this is gonna be my system for
eight hours because it feels like with
heroin if someone overdoses on heroin
you can give them knowledge zone which
is fantastic because it just instantly
reverses it and people just come off
that slump and like they'll hate you for
it because they'll have been having a
nice tour of their trip yeah but
caffeine
I feel like Norfolk's you've just got to
write it now if you ride the wave so I
think as a prop and I like rule of
coffee as well so I normally have no
time for people who advise these sorts
of things especially because you don't
like me you don't like coffee and add 3d
caster they actually did you people made
me think you didn't like savor savor an
iced coffee or buy like nice coffee me I
don't know so I am like that was like
that so giving it was really difficult
to do but definitely benefit so now
what's your relationship with coffee now
or never want to let hear you say this I
feel like this this is it's gonna real
story it's maybe that's maybe the real
Johnny is tied up somewhere this is like
this is the Android this light I think
having seen the having seen the effect
of having two coffees and realizing that
I had blunted that is such a strong like
[ __ ] me like I need to be careful with
this stuff so you're going to start
using it strategically after the 30
is up the thing is is gone right okay
yeah just at one of the movie fine so
this was actually in there what it so
George we have a good podcast about this
like we do johnny has a protocol on how
to reset your coffee addiction without
just going cold turkey because there is
not what I did there is real caffeine
withdrawal effects like you will get
headaches and anything and it's not
psychogenic it's like is pharmacologic
effective immediately I actually found
switching to tea easier than using decaf
right okay I think just because you
aren't like having a ship version or
something you're like popping out zero
caffeine isn't it what do you think it's
awesome and crazy yeah but also like
it's not as an asset if you like coffee
yeah it's lesson to okay if you like
coffee it's awful it's just not as nice
it's just a knockoff but I like
experimenting with different teas and it
is an interesting experience
yeah yeah well I did something called
under the video from the standard
fitness morning routine which I like to
call the anxiety cocktail because what
people do is they'll get us all out of
bed first thing they do you check the
newsfeed on Instagram check if they've
got neurotic you check has ever had any
likes or anything skip breakfast so you
want to external eyes you want to get
outside of yourself as fast as possible
don't you yeah first thing in the
morning so you want to sensitize
yourself to other people's approval and
make sure to prime anybody for stress so
you do that then you skip breakfast so
make sure that you get yourself into the
most sympathetic dominant of glucagon
dominant state that you can then you've
got this cortisol awakening response
you've got a natural surge of stress
hormones coming in peaking it around 45
minutes there's the perfect time to have
a big cup of coffee so that so that when
that starts to get absorbed it just
doubles on that stress response you get
all of that stuff and then you go sit
over a computer hunched over and
multitask and only look at things in the
thirty centimeters away the artificial
light and artificial light make sure to
hammer that and that is hard you don't
turn your notifications off on you have
you notifications come in and all the
time
making a flip between tasks and that is
hard to engineer anxiety in yourself and
I mean check out the videos on my
Instagram but I look at the look at the
rate of anxiety searches on Google from
2004 to now and it's doubled and we
wonder why I did an interview today with
recovery for life which is a substance
abuse and mental health facility in
Newcastle they help people out of
substance they don't give them mental
health problems and substance abuse at
the moment yeah that would be awful it'd
be a poor business model so the hate
crime charity that funds hate crimes
rapists exist no the rayful charity with
what was that thing is a new strength
the rapist
strength arapeta straight it's the
rapist like the pediatrician that got a
brick thrown through his windows of
people to read the sun that wasn't
terrible have you done that's not you
know what mine is and get shall be
pierre all gonna be upset at me for this
because it's not really safe and i this
is a life making your own fuel e no no
this is a life won't be surprised by
importing it from yemen
yeah i'm not saying i mean it's
certainly the yemeni fuel is that it's
against the regulations of these places
and it is just what I do I'm not saying
you should but when it's a cold day and
you want to fill up your car with petrol
when I want to fill up my car with
petrol I put the thing in take the cap
squeeze it underneath the handle and
then get back in the car and then the
petrol runs free throw that hands-free
it will fill up and it will stop on its
own account you can then get back out
you know you want to go and hook it any
city center shell between the hours of
12 and 5 on a weekday there's a rib dude
doing it for cop really attendant yeah
how much do you want met I just don't
kill her you know what I have really
changed my opinion of the frequency of
filling my car fault I know gas are you
going full tank yeah
so there's an interesting story we argue
about this earlier my [ __ ] right the
story of why is that I got started on a
petrol station
so I got started on payment and my local
petrol station Dubai really I'll explain
so the way the format of the petrol
station is ridiculous all that there's a
mini Tesco and the pumps are just off
the road so you come off the road and
you're immediately in a month so that
means that the queues for the pump on
the road move out onto the road so I
have filled up this was like 5:30 going
into the walking into the Tesco and as
I'm doing that the guys like hammering
his horn park behind me turn round and
as a guy like gesturing and I just went
by that like I don't know what you mean
you know I'm just walked in I was with
my girlfriend at the time she filled up
a separate pump also had [ __ ] from
something separate rules both walked at
ridiculous both walked in and I'm
standing in the queue and this guy just
runs in two in two tasks oh no you are
like I just remember it must have looked
really weird to him because it seemed
like I didn't I was just confused I was
like
[Laughter]
unintentionally flushable it's a visual
to say the least
I'm very confrontational accidentally
yes a people either see you as
unapproachable or aggressive escalating
with the adoration so didn't meet sure
there was he said what the [ __ ] you
doing so if you think you are
he said why didn't you move out and or
what and start shouting this and I said
because that's not what people do at a
petrol station but suppose it there was
a security guard there's no nothing the
same TV hardly nothing absolutely
nothing so I'm still queuing while this
guy is just on the other side of the
like tiny barrier and that exists into
order queues and he saw that as being a
glass wall that he couldn't go past so
he's like you know but standing still
sort of a meter away from me and I'm
trying to ignore him get to the front of
the queue go to the the guy pump number
it's the same long activities when you
have a ninja film there's two people
fighting in the middle of a circle and
everyone around the guy behind the till
was like calm down mate calm down don't
do anything it's okay I'm not gonna
fight that man I just want to go home
foot massage and so I then left started
walking out and and back is like just
shell-shocked my whole thing's a sheep
raft at her car and I was kind of like
looking over my shoulder and the guy
again like followed me but stayed a
distance behind and now I should got on
my car and drove off not people preserve
his all because you didn't move away he
feels he felt like I should have filled
up and then moved my car forward into
space I've never seen anyone do that
would have blocked someone else come
around and it would be mayhem but so
what what I think he got annoyed about
was me doing that but what I was trying
to say was like I don't know what the
[ __ ] you do if he wasn't mean to say get
out of the car with us we did but then
he didn't say what he liked only after
the fact to leave like not excuse me
would you mind
but like you want to say may
there is a queue there is a fixed rate
of processing here you have the same
amount of time do you remember when it's
an hour Philip man
now for the Micah let's remember when
that guy got upset because I got near
his beer in London I whe your reaction
was was very good to that I thought
because the guy I can't have already
said to you so I was walking down a set
of steps in Nando's we've been for the
food this guy was sat down with his
family at like 3:00 in the afternoon on
a Saturday having a beer like as you do
when you're a dad with your daughter and
I we went down and I was the closest to
the table as you walk in tandem you
weren't lurching over the tape I was
just like at least two feet I was at
least two feet away from his beer all
right and as I've walked past he said
watch it mid and I turned round and
looked at me at that but just looked he
said you need me hit me being oh look
tough yeah okay yeah right what was the
life hiked out of that Philip you come
with the Phil no that wasn't even a life
it was you so I good do so what's going
no you said what you just did was that
you what so you've gone nicely this is
what happens why I can't have a life
ready yeah look at Mary asked I'm about
to go now right I'm about to even now
see I'm gonna video guiding can compare
vmb I mean and then you're going to go
you're going to go after me okay so this
is a problem no because that's what
happens in this lots of fluid rushing
around that high pressure isn't here
turgid I think of our squeezing of who
will pop that's not because you've got
good grip strength is on probably not
enough to pop that okay so when you go
away on holiday especially for going
around a party holiday abroad the best
way I'll tell you pi
the best way to make sure that your
luggage is not wasteful and also to
remove any performant from Juanita's
[Laughter]
again it confiscated by the Scottish
woman at the checkout okay then woo her
into letting you take it but then on the
way back get stops by some angry German
woman at the airport who were like Chris
tried to take four kilos of Tresemme
shampoo to Iceland for a three-day trip
well it was the only sighs I had fair
enough I mean I think to decant it it
was all brand-new unopened I didn't have
any shampoo it was an awkward time of
batching and I was booked by any what
was more good was the shower it's not
like I didn't in Iceland thing you have
to kneel down you did nothing that what
you had to you had to lie didn't you
just flat so when you're going where do
those at reservation make it better
when you are going away on holiday plan
your outfit for the night time in
advance ideally if you can plan the
daytime as well but rather than just
arbitrarily throwing volumes of clubs
underwear socks trousers etc so perfect
example of this we went to way to Vegas
for my business partner stag do I was
rooming with a guy the guy who I was
rooming with planned his outfit for
night one not two not three not four in
advance including accessories so a
hankerchief or at I assure cufflinks
whatever he needed and then he got that
laid them out first one second one third
one fourth one on an evening time he
knew exactly what he was going to wear
first advantage which is huge because
you don't you you've outsourced the
decision-making not only to a time when
you've got a little bit more awareness
but also to one way you're not on
[ __ ] holidays supposed to be enjoying
yourself and then secondly he had no
wastage of curls everything got one
nothing got wasted that's it like it is
it's a unbelievable tactic I can't
believe I
guess I bet the girls do it actually no
I've got the coins go somehow sake Lord
there's no nothing so I try and do it
but I what I'm what's happened me a
couple times is something's got dirty or
like something's happened then suddenly
the whole thing's ass or thrown into
disarray no you know you need you need
to neutral pieces of buffer clothing
yeah you dig pale blue shirt pair of
blue jeans loading t-shirts that could
be used in a couple of hazard pants
sweatpants covered has a spur socks and
that's it was like the key bits like you
if you if you get your blazer dirty like
whatever go go - oh you'll be fine go
Thomas got topless here get up off tap
tap tap right it's like a turkey breast
one or okay spend time by yourself
it's funny cuz there are people that
spend the only time they spend by
themselves when they're physically
asleep yeah like probably with a partner
in accident hmm-hmm so spend time by
yourself do you mean spend time along
with your own thoughts because you can
be by yourself in a car driving but
listen this applaud radio yeah I was
classically so yeah I think with the
iron on your phone talking to people is
still not by yourself you're fine also
yeah so for it for people who are kind
of interested in self developments
probably there it's really meditation
it's a good way of you are completely by
yourself at that point in all that
exists is is you and your thoughts but I
think just trying to take time away from
constantly try to impress other people
or you know I'm thinking of this
standard kind of nine-to-five worker
life mm-hmm because I just think you
could stimulus you you things build up
and you and like I left unchecked
especially if you work with people
because then you're sat in other
people's energy field constantly yeah
where the crowd of people and you
accumulate
emotional fatigue as well where if
you're in a customer-facing
or even if you're not but particularly
customer-facing
client-facing service delivery type jobs
you have to maintain this kind of
saccharine smile all the time over a
professional face that wears you down
over time and then by the end of the day
that has to be shaken off and it can
only really be done when got discharged
with yourself for some time and it's
it's the reason why I like you know you
have the standard someone comes home
after a a hard day at work or a date
working where they have to talk to
people and the partners that are how's
it going I don't talk to anyone me alone
they're the last person that you want to
vent on so it's once something I get a
benefit I get from the gym even though I
got a critter criticized that have not
very social
like I quite like it's just like me a
difficult task
my thoughts it's not complicated
likewise we do love you you do you to
have your phone I do have my phone I do
that's so for me to upgrade that the gym
does the phone yeah leave the phone
behind you use if you need to track your
lifts use a whiteboard if you're a
proper good gym or still haven't done
that that was life hacks 101 and I still
need to put your phone on well why not
give up your phone you get their iPod
shuffle yeah I think I'll need to
replace it with them so one of the
problems is using obviously a modern
phone for a lot of people is their music
blu-ray those ones where they take notes
sat-nav
yeah it's bluetooth bluetooth headphones
fixes to the music problem mmm notepad
and pen fixes tracking lifts so the time
one thing I like mm-hm you've said a
model for people who maybe aren't doing
as much introspective work but then
moving forward if I mentioned this
before I can't remember where if you
were told to go to sit in a room for 30
minutes on your own and you couldn't
meditate mmm with nothing nothing to do
no stimulus hmm I would say even for me
as an only child who spends the vast
majority of his time on his own don't be
pre testing so that you know a moment
yep you know the provision of moment the
other thing did you you did so on the
phone boot camp thing of that that was
one of the tasks
and I ended up doing it did you thirty
minutes in a room without meditating not
just sit and on a chair what you just
sit and think but you just what do you
think of it you do it in the house yeah
is it knowing to be lost in thought when
you spend a lot of time sat on your own
in silence trying to not be lost in
thought when you met I'd say at the time
I didn't give it that much thought
weirdly I was like I'm just gonna go sit
there for now it's all I want Becca
comes in what are you doing she's used
to it no way Chatterley
so I are you facing the wall as well
facing the corner so it's just I was
just sucked
I think up yeah just sucked looking at
the ceiling fair enough
well I like the dressing test spend
spend some time I mean you can double
this up there's so much low-hanging
fruit this stuff like this you can
double up with going in nature hmm like
I'll add that on top go Betty
yeah go on grass in nature bare feet
lovely looks so much lower I read
something through this
I have no attraction to the nature thing
I don't know why so far from the beach I
buy the beach every every morning and
every evening now I'm doing probably
maybe between 2 and 5 minutes of just
standing outside and just even if it's
rare even if it's been it's been
absolutely pouring down before first
thing in the morning go outside and
stand in the rain so it's safe or for
those who want some kind of reason to do
this but there are physiological
benefits to being at the beach breathing
the the negative ions that are released
from the salt and the sea or from some
kind of pheromone like compound the
trees release so he go into nature are
lots of greenery they have some kind of
tranquillizing effect you also looked
you did a meta-analysis on birthing yeah
I mean to call that matter analysis is a
bit of a I think a strategy but anything
you have you totally I did I looked a
lot the research I've done so I'm
grounding yeah and that does is
hippie-dippie as it sounds have some
standing on grass on bare feet so I'm I
think the main thing the library
cortisol the main thing for me aside
from believing any of the wus
these are just like to be outside for a
little bit first thing in the morning
first and blasting at night after a
shower hot shower and then outside a
moment it's really cold but for some
reason just being able to look up at the
sky see the stars see the moon
feel the wind broadly it's really really
grounding and it's very present because
you are forced with zero distractions
you're forced to only experience the
sensations that you're occurring then in
there so it's quite nice I think what
thinking about - I think what has pissed
me off about the whole thing is a
business coach that told me to do it
yeah isn't it horrible that people can
spoil a brief lull very Marcus I would
love to try the bone broth but he's just
annoyed you all braid letting his bird
get blasted all over by her boyfriend
blasted I strive to take Texas to get
pasted by so I wouldn't recommend salt
and water salt and lemon and water would
be warning ya behold foresters have
given the show his wife's game but he
also talks about straw you're my student
why do you want your easy yeah but you
don't know he's up to
listen or brace in hospital with a half
a face no is he was IDO trashed his car
behind this unfortunate it's the
westerly man that didn't go on a break
right there he's gone so in last life
hacks episode 105 we covered Toby which
is a Chrome extension that allows you to
put a bunch of stuff it sounds lame but
it to put a bunch of different things
into it like so you can have a reading
queue and listening queue you're
watching queue and so it allows you to
capture things that people send you and
arrange them in a certain way it's a
very clever bookmark manager
very yeah really really good for that
and it allows you to have one across the
top that's like frequently visited
websites and also you can save sessions
so if you have multiple sessions open
multiple tabs open and you want to
resume that later you can save it all
down and call it the name of a certain
project you can have like if you working
on project for one thing and that
requires for websites to be open you can
see right on there and so on so that's
Toby it's only available on chrome there
isn't a phone
and so I needed something that allows me
when I don't have my laptop and I want
to work through the queue of articles
that you guys have sent me and I want to
read them to be able to quickly access
them without thinking I was a scroll
back through the messages or any of any
of that nonsense and just be able to
quickly resume that so I use pocket for
that there is an equivalent map called
instapaper
now pocket is great but they updated it
last week to include a text-to-speech
function I've already got so so they've
made it more natural sounding not right
before it was like it hmmso them voice
it's all speaker webpage are you yeah
but with it with us we'll sort of Siri
like voices so now I'm able to read
articles that people have sent me on the
drive to work in the morning the school
read listen listen
yeah which is [ __ ] portable there is
a paid version but what's the approach
what you get you get no yeah more than
three highlights per article and no
answer yet really into pregnant cuz I
had when I was doing lots of commuting I
remember thinking I wish I could read a
bit so you have them ready yeah I've got
it now
cuz it's um so there's a Mac version
underthrown version they synchronized oh
it might even mean like if you haven't
got to be all pocket yet start with just
pockets because they seek an expander
you have a love Toby it's you know what
I'd love to know whether lots of other
people have that need capture I think
the only reason that you would hop out
rate for articles and things terribly
late so the only reason you would have
that need is if you like to read stuff
like if you're not first off if you're
not getting sent or fine discovering it
a lot yourself and then saying if you're
not actually bothered about reading it
if loads of your friends send you [ __ ]
that you don't care about yeah if your
friends lend you something he just
delete yeah yeah it's Toby's right isn't
it doesn't matter yeah exactly remove
the friend I think what I normally do
when people send me stuff if it's an
article is I'll skim skim it but it like
books or podcasts I'll do the full thing
and so the IVA process is portable and
podcasts but articles I tend [ __ ] I've
captured
process yeah so either on wunderlist I
but I have a reading list and I'm
listening to it okay for those two
things that's a good one let's go so I'm
gonna go with six minute diary because
Johnny you have recently still doing it
to do it today it's still going on so
six minute diary anyone who's been
listening for a little while with hurt
me bring this up before it is a daily
journal three minutes of mourning three
minutes an evening prompted questions
that they geared towards things that
science says makes you happier so
gratitude long-term goals instantiated
in the daily habits and looking for
areas of improvement that's broadly
where it works from before you start it
there's a 60 page buy in which for
anyone who does CrossFit will know what
that is it's a moderately large hoax
it's a small text and big pages so a lot
of reading take it'll take you a few
days to get through the 60 pages
depending on your reading speed and it's
there's like 40 references I think in
that so it's very impressive
the it's not just someone hasn't just
put together some super some space for
your ice and gratitude and good deeds
and stuff there's a lot of thinking
behind the book the quotes that are done
every day yeah pretty you know what I
think is the best part about it for me
is the weekly questions awesome so yeah
every everyday you do three minutes in
the morning three minutes evening some
days it takes a little longer obviously
but um broadly I think that's probably
not far off how long it takes and it
encourages you susannah Hallinan the
what science may take what science saves
makes you happy a podcast that I did
with her on that she said that gratitude
is the foundation for happiness and this
is a really good tool to develop doing
some gratitude I've never once kept up
with a journal before but I have done
with the six minute diary and yeah every
week there are some fairly probing
questions that force you to do some
introspective work so if you've never
actually got round to doing any self
inquiry and some interest
of stuff I think this is a really good
place to start if you think our what
meditation might be a bit woowoo for me
or you struggle to slow yourself down a
little bit I think it's a first step
into introspective work it's 19 pounds
on Amazon
it'll be night on the bridge grams and
prayin and it's fantastic so I put one
for my sister know if you bought one for
two of her friends be kidding yeah since
you got yours yeah that's fantastic
yeah I think it's it's what I like about
it is for me to sit and explain to
someone like I think you should be doing
some introspection and try gratitude and
it's like they don't listen
yeah if you just buy them something it's
a nice gift and they that intro takes it
takes them through it takes us through
the benefits and it's so low commitment
yeah
it's a good it's a good it does tick a
lot of boxes keeps the right price point
for a good present for someone like it
might be quit it's a good good price
point to get someone a present it's a
low investment in yourself it lasts for
five months and they've just released
the six minute diary pure it's just like
it it's the seven month one so between
the first one that you get with the
intro bit and the second one you get
full 12 months right between the two but
you don't need the buy-in again on sex
offender
yeah no same thing has 60 pages have
taken up with Jonas and yeah I honestly
could not recommend this one thing that
I've still not done but I really want to
do is the bit the thing the first task
they tell you to do is send there are
loads of services that you can do just
so send an email I'll send it back to
you
save me yeah so it says like send an
email to yourself in five months time of
like stuff you're worrying about what
where you think that'll where you'll be
mine came through to me I sent one about
five six years ago oh my god and it came
through to me the other month I forgot
what it said I think it was nothing
nothing that I found them no it would I
think it was like the struggles that I
had at the time and all that stuff I
look back and I was like really yeah
which was nice [ __ ] because that no one
no should do it we should all do fine
just you and so she did you indeed so
Johnny you're up next should we do one
more round each or if you got something
got a couple of quick ones if you want
to do I for any quick ones I've got
loads of great ones so this is a this is
a bit bit nasty but um so it's related
to some of the stuff that I've been
considering with the weekly questions in
the six minute diary but just so in
keeping with the idea that everyone is
caught up in the of the struggle for
penis and the feeling better anymore
blah blah blah asking yourself very
probing questions to try and just check
that you're on the right path for you
when you're making decisions that are
right for you so things like like if I
died tomorrow weren't I be happy with
how my life has been so far do I feel
like I'm making the right decisions do I
feel like I'm setting good examples for
other people when am I truly happy when
am I truly sad where am I sedating to
try and get away from the critical
questions or the critical things that
are really bothering me and that it's
linked to spending time alone and
thinking about these things because I
think that stuff people talk about self
development mm-hmm and think that that
means that they should start reading or
that they should start meditating but
actually just sitting and thinking about
those questions that are often very
difficult to to think about like am I
actually happy with how my life is now I
do I spend a good chunks of my time in a
good mood or in a bad mood who is it
that promotes those things who is it
that worsens those things the clues in
the name write self development it's an
inquiry of the self but it's that
stuff's not an app and it's not trendy
and it's really [ __ ] just essentially
the about page of the new modern wisdom
website which will be up at some point
it's said in that introspective work is
a nobody business and through everyone
rock that you turn over which is clean
underneath there's 20 which are filthy
and something terrifying is hiding below
any like that's exactly that's the
canucks they've accurate proportion as
well yeah if you do a little bit of self
Kurian nothing comes up you'll oh bloody
hell and all that you can be certain of
is that the next 19 could be [ __ ]
[ __ ] so let related to that asking
yourself like why my personal social
media why am i drinking why am i
bitching about this person and just
sitting and thinking cuz there's always
like a in everyone's experience like
here here real why behind something I
just think I think there's a tendency
for I don't want to think about lacks
it's uncomfortable so I'll just do this
other thing instead is there a guiding
principle or a guiding mantra that
people can use to bring themselves back
to finding the truth and to avoid hiding
or to avoid taking the first easy answer
that comes to mind when they ask
themselves those questions maybe you're
worried yes so one one way to really
leverage the power of the unconscious
mind the unconscious mind is simply
every thought that you are not looking
at right now it's not some mysterious
thing 95 95 percent of our actions every
day oh just dreaded alarm crunches so
there are deeper levels below that which
maybe we're not aware of until we start
to do there was up doing more digging
deep but the unconscious mind is very
good at pulling together lots of cross
correlations of unrelated stuff and
processing large volumes of data while
you're not paying attention to it that
the brains always kind of just sifting
things over and dealing with that so if
you ask yourself a question that you're
not immediately sure of the answer of
you can ask yourself before bed mother
over for a while hold it in your
consciousness and then drop it and go to
sleep and then just sleeping and
allowing it to process on its own but
with the conscious running intention to
answer it will then start to bring up
more and more answers and you'll have
definitely experienced this where you'll
have had a problem that you just didn't
think about for a while a few days later
the answer pops into your head because
it's just been processing in the
background or you read a book and then
actually concepts from the book start to
make a bit more sense after you've had a
couple of nights sleep it's come
together again a Greg
what's-his-name part about this Greg
Potter talked about this as well same
concept
so ask before bed especially the probing
ones and the ones that maybe I'm
uncomfortable to answer we know a lot of
it double down on that as well you can
like to start taking a dream journal and
in the mornings don't move like once you
wake up and it's hard to remember to do
this but just stay in the same position
and try and verbally recall it much of
your dream is you hard as you can and
then do that for a few days once you've
done that you get into the habit of
teaching your brain to remember your
dreams write them down and sometimes
symbols do come up in dreams and they
usually quite obvious this dream
symbology is the much research not not
though like so some people have gone
full blue and taken like if you see a
spider it means this and if you see
cabbage it means that but like I think
ultimately you will be aware enough of
that if you write it down and give it a
few hours and know us you know it's
really painful as someone who first off
tries to promote reduction in turkeys
and secondly is working hard on his own
I have a lot of dreams there me on my
phone right the Reilly phone I am on oh
man which is like being tortured well
usually that's it my equivalent are
being tortured while I'm asleep so a way
to lucid dream is to like check your
phone or you watch look away and then
look back and if the numbers are
scrambled or they're different hmm from
every hunt I think three hard you but
then if you're so good at looking at
your home in your dream that actually it
you can have a full whatsapp group chat
well that's exactly what it is and then
that's that's like the pipe bypass thing
for the breaths that I've managed to do
with meditation fall into automatic
thinking and you know I'd be able to get
to I I think are definitely given a full
day be able to get to a thousand so
there's a way I fart around that okay so
what I've started doing is start at the
bottom of my left nostril right so
listen is it this is this is like kreyòl
and meditation so forgive me so breath
focus on just about my my left nostril
twenty breaths
and then I move slightly round by left
nostril and I change when I count the
breath so I might be like one two to
keep yourself away well eat one you got
a massive
TV or other two brats through season 4
284 284 cool earnest but so then every
20 breaths to move the location and just
change when you when you note the brazos
really like breath 1 are you doing 1 1
in and out is one breath yeah yes and
what's so weird is I can move all the
way around my nostril into the laser
focus on my left nostril and I'm like so
air my left nostril switching my right
nostril isn't close to possible hmm I'm
like no no how's my right well the got
my right hemisphere of your brain is
responsible for viewing and sensing
everything on the left hand side of your
body right and the other way and the
left hemisphere is responsible for that
and the left and right are also
responsible for different thought
positive things someone I would endure
if the left side of your brain is
struggling a little bit more within
advice so what it feels like is just
because by the time I changed nostrils
it's like 150 breaths I've just all I've
been thinking about for like 15 minutes
was just this nostril and it feels like
changing is quite challenging but as
their goal the wall to get over yeah the
thing that you have said after is
retreat with like people getting really
caught up in the complexities of
meditation and the guy just kept saying
Roxanne foster death tip you know yeah
the teacher was very good at like four
five days there's the daily meeting with
the teacher everyone gets to go up and
speak to him five minutes and people
have these little stories about like and
the only practice you have in the first
five days is is focus on this part
breathe
that's all you can tell out of the I'm
experiencing this thing I'm struggling
with you or not I'm getting this
tingling sensation he but like just
focus on the breath keep your attention
on the nose on the inhale and on the
exhale and between the breaths you have
three jobs
[Laughter]
yeah who doesn't know the story in the
skirt I was like maybe 20 if he has cuz
he has to change it all the time we've
been again now he's maybe 21 now isn't
it oh yeah I must be
there's a bear in mind that every year
treats a hundred hours and this man's
done 2012 the day at least he made years
no practice outside of meditation
retreats which is very unlikely a true
seven or eight months it's you know time
and attention because this the reason
that I can't my breaths derail eNOS but
the reason I can't brace is cos your
podcast at Daniel Ingraham no need to
listen to it you said raged like give me
a which is what I was like you said
program II asked him like what how do I
start with meditation and he was just
saying if you just sit for 20 minutes
and you kind of like vaguely focused
like that's an okay session if you get
to a hundred breaths good session try
get to a thousand just use it as a way
of measuring pro its it just makes sense
to me it's how I do everything else my
that's a rut then it's very transparent
very measurable we tried the one way you
do this is what I've done this is a
headspace one breathe in and out for one
up to Tanzania
this is the legs um
count to ten and then stop the focus on
the breath completely quiet time I've
checked lately blank the mind and allow
all thoughts to just be reflections in
the pool so you're not actually focusing
on anything and that's a really good one
because that's as much silence as you
can get without attaching you so because
when you're focusing on the breath you
are still focusing on the thought oh
this is the sensation this is the number
so it doesn't feel like that because it
it's sensation sensation and it's almost
like thought go sensation sensation
cessation thought without without the
sensation at all is what this next bit
was it was interesting
I feel like we're getting can you focus
on nothing
it's is this floodlight vs. spotlight
here the this there's a third method so
you doesn't everyone get into this spot
spotlight says you have an object of
meditation and you're focusing on that
floodlight is that you have open focus
and you are you are the point of
awareness that anything is going through
any sensations you and that's focus on
so full of light there is no object you
are just well see other open focus the
third one is the self inquiry which is
similar to floodlight but you are
turning the subject of subjective
consciousness back on itself like who is
it that's thinking yeah who is it was
here really not weird because
conceptually like you can't taste your
own tongue or feel your own finger or
see your own I like Chris can't believe
it's not butter as well so yeah are you
saying that before yeah yeah earlier on
that's one the life like he thinks
Marmite okay yes so one with you mind it
so did we do sinus rinse no last time no
I am obsessed with the Neal med sinus
rinse I got this from dr. clay height
who's a natural bodybuilder old tea
nation guy he
he's a bodybuilder he play likes lifting
weights and so I have a confession
okay I used mine right and I didn't
record me using there's nothing dramatic
happened didn't this well I've got a
video of traumatic things happening
using my sinus rinse so I can I can send
it to video Martine and he can so it's
not really noise what is it so what it
is is anything and it it's it's
recommended by ENT ear nose and throat
doctors as well because if you have
chronic sinusitis lots of sinus
infections a2p hay fever any of those
kind of things where sinuses are blocked
ATP ATP like so if you get a general
constellation of like eczema and hay
fever and itchy nose and a lot of stuff
go and just check this out watch the
video of me doing it but I want to do
that it's a bottle squeezy bottle of
saline solution and you squeeze it into
your nostril comes out the other nostril
and Claire's are all of the gunk that's
in your nose at the same time do in the
morning Shirley was listening to lovely
position your tongue in you so if you
have to yeah you might go for a so you
so tell me about this right
I would some I standing my bathroom
bottle salt read the back do you not use
tap water so caspak twice and I used to
use tap water it's not a small thing
I'll just use bottled water bottled
water put the salt in and it's like
pointing up nose on squeeze never do it
without the salt as well
knocks really yeah with the salt
perfectly painless and lovely but
without the surface and it's looking
like you've done a back flip in a pool
and you know you like are horrible so
I'm there I am bottle in my nose I'm
thinking like rationally what do I
understand about my nose like I think
that this goes up and then probably in
and I imagine down someone then I know
that I breathe but that goes in my lungs
yeah I don't want water in my lungs yeah
but it says correctly the nostril I'm
thinking well how
could happen but here we go see you like
you have to bend down suppose that's
what prevents it from and you squeeze
and there's a delay like squeegee like
if that happens that they like fit you
feel your face fill up just goes you've
got this time people don't always get it
for re just I think I'm so used to just
you would have very following this
prophet things things that feel a bit
unusual bit strange gonna do it anyway
you're an animal
no would you yeah you let's video it not
the first time from the top half
caffeine anime Ben green fields big into
them
what is that caffeine another just you
just coffee any bone okay I assume as
you say coffee I think it's a very
studio scientific thing that people love
it why do you good time except probably
but I don't think it is I think can
Ruben healthy bacteria is it gonna have
anything very of them any liquids
particular like should people have water
part of the muck say line is it good
hind anything of people so is it an
immersed your first big reference a line
up your bum and all the pic come up yeah
I mean I think unless there's a problem
and you need you need to I would stay
away from putting things in Ipoh I mean
I think that's a safe several million
years of evolution would have programmed
something in there's a guy who's never
going to own a business is just putting
people's bums who are yeah yeah who like
people with problems he puts pay up pop
- they don't have right the pill that's
right through everything and say he gets
people who have got their good poop and
he puts the poo then put the good poop
that Johnny I would pay you to teach
medicine just like so what you have to
do is like read the textbook press s
they insert a new that kind of speak
right how much would I have to pay you
to let me put someone else's who in your
bond without medical supervision
mmm no medical supervision so
so do I need the boom I don't know so
you're just putting it at my bone as you
are right now how are you going to do it
love however unadvised by the medical
personnel okay it's a proper procedure
but someone else's peer 250 grand
children so you wouldn't do for
underground a hundred grand
hundred grand you wouldn't put someone
else's pillow people so I understand
that when I say yes he'll go 90 this is
what I did people visit I do it all the
time for the sake of this podcast 250
grand one's a solid floor I see self up
once I stop recording you and I could
have I think I've seen Queens that I can
think of pricey support like there is no
market this is the market no but if you
want to put them on I don't think you're
gonna find a buyer for us but the Chris
is the only buyer I'm not selling I'm
not very good turn 50 grand
it's like someone coming up to you
saying I want your house mmm like
there's there's a level of hassle
associated that's irrelevant of the
price right but you just factor that
into the price so much I've done 250
grand Nate you are over price in your
ass in your opinion
I mean you the master of your own if you
want to put my button there's a number
how much would you how much you have to
pay you to put your own poo back in your
bump well using a tool just like I'm
doing it this time no you're doing it
but it's your poop and you know if
you're actually doing this I'm not gonna
be right oh I see
plot thickens explain with the variables
he said again is it mad at me super fun
it yes by the exact same it's everything
at like are your mates the adopters or
not by them not by him right he's not
that he's gone I do that for a dealer
for 50 grand so vacuum so 200 run
there's the differential between someone
else's poo and your poo yeah 200 runned
what you worried about just these are
just arbitrary fingers Chris and what am
I worried a time you've just really what
I'm worried about someone else's poo and
that Yusuf has just said I would steer
clear of putting anything up you bum
Vidya Mandy in stinking
I've I've brought extra battery
[Laughter]
okay here guys like I need to know what
I really want to know is how much would
it would you have to be paid to have
someone else's people put up you got is
the person who's pony's disease-free yes
Oh fine
well yeah how much 50 grand and how much
for your on big that's a big discount
there mate I'll take it
cuz you got your fact of differentiation
is much greater than mine yeah well to
be honest I have to do a bit of reading
give me two hours and I'll come back
with a revised offer
I might lower it I'm eyedropper tool it
to round what how would you lower it
there's no incentive to learn it if he's
agreed to pay it I haven't agreed to
that but if you want because I've tuned
I'm quarter million please on the
bargain yeah you are you are a bargain
plus let's be honest it would be more
funny if I do you that maybe it would
make for a good content really fantastic
content right my final one what am I
going to do
[Music]
okay so I've mentioned this on the how
to get lean few summer holiday podcast
but didn't go into it with quite so much
detail or as much further skier and
natural set to yogurt I swear every life
hacks do you say skier and it's always
and I'm like Chris honestly mate I
couldn't agree more jump when are you
just after just shortly after I nearly
died nice endure cold you know I got
back to the was this one he got a lot
drenched this is the first night yeah
the night after I'm very classy close to
death it got back and I bought
strawberries gear and I just remember
thinking this
honestly I was like alive that I
wouldn't be able to replicate it was so
nice I think we'd all convinced
ourselves that because it was Icelandic
Icelandic people are really good at
convincing you that if something is
Icelandic it's worth nine and a half
thousand pounds and healthy really not
well they just caught every even the
butter but Icelandic bucks at Icelandic
water coffee and see how Icelandic
butter that kneading it with a spoon you
like the skier was brilliant bloody
lovely what's what's your reasoning to
me is that Allah the dairy because I
don't like them how much have managed to
buy the would skier Wow yeah that is
interesting because that's like someone
opening yogurt in China so I better the
Icelandic people just like as I've
experienced firsthand their skier is
superior its head and shoulders a book
yeah and it's so like you it wouldn't
bother your food if the micros on it
wouldn't believe my little it's a
protein supplement essentially is if you
owned a company for three argument sake
was like the name of a fruit and you
made bikes and then another company that
was also called the name of that fruit
was able to sue you because they had a
monopoly on a fruit you think that was
ridiculous and yet any of these words if
we cease and desist we will we always do
so I what do you think about far hey
I've not a father you know what it is f
AG like most pronounced it's fine yeah
if a total total yogurt you must have
done no you would have seen it it's like
the Emperor that there is always under
supermarkets it's like the big it's five
quid toriel yeah yeah maybe I [ __ ]
hope that I didn't get the final total
is fried yogurt so the that's zero not
the some people by the two or the full
if you buy a full fat yogurt it is it's
I've been punched in the stomach just
full fat calories watts it's the little
[ __ ] are you man again isn't it
drinking for fuckload for you had it
before diamond private with Johnny had a
keno thing of yogurt with four double
deckers in it go have a mock Christmas
this one you were so the Nama left the
great thing about no I was cutting at
the time the great thing about both of
them double-decker is a 250 calories
servant of mainly carbs and fat
fantastic so you can only eat macaroni
on a few yeah a full double deckers in a
tub of total yogurt is roughly 50 grams
of protein little bit of carbs zero fat
mix them together what have you got
you've got a creamy double-decker based
dessert trial have like a fish and chips
mitad was that available at the time
fishing chain I was in Dom's in Tesco I
was in Sainsbury's I see trying to try
to make ends meet
instead of making into me run adjust fit
made your fitness month need you're
getting doubled up well I really agree I
think Tesco own-brand
low fat yogurt low-fat Greek style
yogurt yep is there so you want a ladies
one scoop one scoop of protein powder
some blueberry great not like mixed nuts
honey
no all right got half don't eat the Cubs
it's not happen yogurt is there is there
on Carrodus of my life like I so many
things go with yogurt for me I did sorry
me know if I don't know what to have it
starts with yogurt what cheese it's the
interchange of the sweet world isn't it
it is I mean like easily achieve is a
savory yogurt it's just cheese just
unfortunately they've tried to make
high-protein low-fat cheeses and it just
doesn't curse I've seen it that blue
stuff it's not very nice it tastes like
tasteless palms up it's got the texture
of parmesan without the rich flavors
[ __ ] it man how do you feel about doing
good yeah like it but I'm having to
limit it because of my estrogen
experiment there's a lot of things I
can't do with my session experiment
principally sick of your science how
many weeks six weeks notice how long's
me go I'll retest my almost eight weeks
yeah and then they find out I think what
happen is it'll be slightly different
but we'll be looking at two isolated
sets of data that anything could be
influencing and you just not touch
receipt I finally get back to using
shower gel yeah and because currently
you're using Ecover washing up liquid
you're using in a ceramic can we in a
ceramic part
can we just say the sentence again of
what you're doing in the show so I use
eco for washing up liquid I'm not using
shampoo is that's another experiment
writing about it I didn't go through the
apple cider vinegar things I think your
head
Steve I'm glad that there's lines in the
sand about what's to weed yeah I think
so it's all under like what might the
GMC take a human if you just stayed at
home all day I didn't have to go
anywhere by the UV using apple cider
vinegar right now probably oh yeah so
got rid of lavender spray or lavender
products normal candles have to get
beeswax candles edamame beans edamame
beans not allowed no no Cologne and a
thought no fragrances minimize dairy fat
switch my teeth paper so you can't blow
[ __ ] you could have fire yogurt yeah oh
I've had a knot of musing a non
fluoridated toothpaste called a youth
thymol she liked the 1930s notice it's
really it's just taste of Cologne Armand
Hammer it's really like no yeah you
can't touch carpets or vinyl floor like
what other floor is that but this would
all be that vinyl yeah not touching
receipts and then the cover washing
liquid and a steel protein shaker
what are you done today there's still
progress know that my steel protein
shake is must bow fun to us yeah so good
piss is all over normal ones anyway
thank you very much what have we got
coming up out run your own business and
the dangers that are associated with
going on your own strength training
truth as a super power relationships 103
what else and we've got a whole bunch of
questions that we need to go through QA
we should initiate interview
you Vidya Monte did he got Dean what
about Mandy all of the BMD yeah three GD
v GD sounds like DD big dick energy over
there no right K Biden thank you k buddy
[Music]